ich fühle mich super und das wird im
moment wo er zwischen den scheiben wenig
zu bieten
[Musik]
für manche war longo wieder krank sind
sie kam für magath langzeitfolgen von
corona sondern zusätzlich die zweifel
und vorurteil die erschöpfung und
müdigkeit unkonzentriertheit
[Musik]
am anfang vom inneren recherche zu dem
film mache ich von u5 youtube zum
betroffene finde der post berühmt über
200 kommentare und die meister wurde
kommentiert ein treiber coxon film
behauptet unter anderem dass es
lankowitz mitgibt bin gespannt auf die
märchenstunde longo wieder schnell
fündig scheinen nicht viele zu sein
sonst müsste danach nicht gesucht werden
ihre wirklich seele so kommentars der
j-league existenz von comics wie flat
und ich persönlich finde dass ich
befremdlich wie ich zu dass man nach
kronach an langzeitfolge h&s stelle es
mir auch recht schwierig vor dass wenn
wir lang hat mit zweifel an der
krankheit konfrontiert wird und ein
vielleicht sogar fort verwirrt dass man
stimuliert oder dass man sogar liegt ich
war diese finde wie betroffene gimmicks
wie viel ein symptom umgehend um in oslo
fand sich tatsächlich apps dutzend
personen konnte wo unter longo bietet
jankovic übrigens ein sammelbegriff
beschwerden wonach der korona erkrankung
auftritt zu den symptomen gehören unter
anderem kopfweh erschöpfung und
atemprobleme ich bin auf dem weg ins
bündnerland die fichte davids er hat
sich auf - luft mulde und ist gerade
da wir die polizisten körperlich fit
letzten winter hatte corona k und
nachher immer wieder mit atemnot und
panikattacken
notausgang haben wir einfach nicht
wissen ja was ist
ich möchte dass du wissen wie es mit dem
rauchen die welt ist zerbrochen ich
merke dass im sinne symptoms schafe
macht und frag mich wie er mit zwiebel
halle mit um gott sowohl igor kennedy
hat das akzeptiert und die kohlen vorher
aufbauten motiviert hat einfach was in
den medien ist schade dass ich schon
dort wenn das ließ sich im instagram im
facebook etc da denke mir schon her ich
glaube an ck und der japaner chemikalien
kajüten neuen umfeld wo vielleicht
übersehen wirklich schwer erkrankt sind
ich denke momentan gleich erstreckt sich
im fröhlich hatte david diagnose longo
wettbüro wie es immer schlechter
gegangen ist hatte den jungen urteil zu
schaffen und trotzdem ist total
erschöpft sie sie in die lunge und herz
sind mechanisch in ordnung und trotzdem
hat das gefühl dass er richtig luft
bekommt er ist jetzt seit sechs wochen
in der reha und gott die sogenannte
reflektorisch die atemtherapie die half
ihm egal
das ist für die leitung ist alles okay
trotzdem trat das sind verzerrt sich die
kluftinger krimis hinserie abgeflachte
art mich und selber der ddr stufe nur
daube und hyperventilieren haut dem
biber und
anderen ganze abschlachten buch hat mich
und so das ganze
dreidimensionale fähig denn den kommt
natürlich eine gewisse angst dazu ja und
es sind so viele punkt wo denn quasi auf
einlass steckt und demnach ohne druck
das war ja ganz auf das sie haben so
eine brücke - konnte ich will mein beruf
sport ja das ja gespannt das dämliche
zusätzlichen einfluss hat die ich schon
gigantisch
ja
haben treten ließen deshalb dass
patienten behandeln wir unter ich sage
immer postnatale depression mal auch
nicht unbedingt aber die mir auch ins
klo es gibt ganz viele krankheiten
trotz dem behandler
ob ich es gesehen und nicht am david sie
nicht gott mir nach und sie zeigt mir
das land wirklich jung ich schon die
menschen aus der bahn werfen
als paar tage später bin ich wieder
unter wachsen wo man sich geschichten
erzählen von
höchster bahnhof gefasst
der bäckerei die partnerin romy hat sich
nach einer
ecke holt sich jetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
übrigens tanzlehrerin und frank rieg
körperlich und kognitiv
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ist romed kliniken
lange kampf bevor wir überhaupt
geschafft und
nach dem 4
die
einfach so
im kopf und
macht alles erschöpft ist alles
und es ist mal
schluss
einfach die luft reinigen wir in jede
dagegen wirbel aber es macht kreis sehen
sich gedanken machen was in dieser woche
nicht aber nur schon übermorgen will es
kommt sowieso anders
und mir dadurch ein da und sogar
unterhalb der knochen andere
die ich das eigentlich sie haben dadurch
ernst genug fühlt vorerst und ärztin
eva walter mega unterschied zwischen den
einzelnen charakter also da ein tierarzt
war ziemlich abgelöscht gebundenheit ja
also
sehr cardoso sie hat wahrscheinlich
einfach eine depression und
kreditwachstum
zu
dir kommen aber das rührt
in der frage dass es nicht stimmt aber
es ist trotzdem nicht so cool
ich weiß
80.000
luftnummer nur drei wochen seitiger
zustand wie es letztes jahr oder im juli
xiii ist also nicht auf andere werke
selber kreil und qualität merke ich wie
auch sieglitzer hat unter der situation
und auch sie sich jetzt muss erhole von
der
db ag als male gemacht weil ich wähle
wisse wie viel man sei in der schweiz
lang die hand und medienstelle hat mich
dann an herr dr
ich leite vom institut für epidemiologie
an der uni zürich und mitgründer von
forschungsprogramm corona unita und er
jetzt ganz kostet achtung es wenn wir
das bezahlen
ich würde von 15 bis 20 der korona
infizierten ausgehen die nach drei bis
sechs monaten noch probleme haben wobei
vielleicht 10 bis 20 prozent davon also
weniger als fünf prozent der infizierten
schwerere lankowitz verläufe sind
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber ich
find 15 bis 20 prozent ein recht hoher
anteil ich habe bis jetzt zum glück kein
corona kann mit mega angst davor mich
hart stecken aber wenn ich die zahl ist
und mir vorstellen dass ich noch eine
akute erkrankung im moment lang kein
problem
damit
es meldet sich normaler beruf mit
online-aufruf steffi schrieb mir dass
sie sich wieder ausbildung zur
rettungssanitäterin mit corona
angesteckt hat und zwar beim transport
von corona patientin trotz langzeitfolge
wie migräne hat sie nur mehrere männer
twitter geschafft sie hat sich recht
langweilige stolz dass es eher eine gut
gott geschweige denn dass sie longo vita
bis sie dann im juni werkstatt
kopfschmerzen krank geschrieben wurde
ist jetzt ist sie sie zwei männer die
heinz land
mehrere zeugen wie so oft wird man
wahrscheinlich nicht sagen aber er kurz
wahrscheinlich nicht gut und sie ist ja
immer man nicht einmal schaffen sondern
wird man einfach sagen
ganz normales und jedes eben nicht und
ich glaube zum einen kann ich das
wahrscheinlich relativ gut auch
versteckt dass es mir innerlich
überhaupt nicht gut und zum anderen ist
halt auch junge
schwarze mitfahrer den wald nicht so
erfahrenen 8 grad steffi verzeiht mir
dass jeder arbeitgeber mir eine diagnose
therapie und sie jetzt nach vorne pusht
dass sie wieder bald zurück und
hat die vier therapie anfangen wo sie
lernt ihr die energiegut teile bisher
hat ihre der arzt waldbad empfohlen das
half ihre energie zu finden iris große
ziel sie will zurück in job als
rettungssanitäterin und
[Musik]
das ist ja genau das war halt irgendwie
mussten ins spital bringen ist
eigentlich angst ich noch mal ausstechen
wenn die airline
nicht also nicht unbedingt wahnsinn
schafe sondern allgemein hat ein
verliebter bildet war dass
ich da nicht so aber und halten
und unternehmen sage ja ist es nicht so
schlimm ich mir gott so gut also ich bin
nicht krank und dann hat genauso eine
person aus stecker für mich war mein
system sind störfall nicht unbedingt das
so so bezwang ist
einer der besten werte
ich merke
mir mit mit einem schwarzen
krawatte gang sachen formuliert und
jetzt ist wie dieser punkt aber nicht
die einfachsten wird
irgendeiner weise infrage kommen
zum glück sind wir jetzt dann gleich im
wald damit sich eine rolle gesucht als
plötzlich
natur und energie tanken
schwindel
[Gelächter]
das ist
genau das machen wir jetzt einfach
essbar minute an bord sitzen und am wall
zu lassen mal mitmachen
[Musik]
dass
ich meine ich glaube die verzerrte zwei
stunden hab ich dann wirklich so was bin
ich eigentlich worden nämlich opel omega
fröhlich ist und so gerne wir sprudeln
wir sind noch nicht so richtig zusammen
ich hoffe ich dass ich hier absolut und
ich möchte man geschafft hätte ich mal
schmidt diese oder ganztag aber nie dran
machen will ich kann
spiel' jetzt zurück vom dreh mit steffi
und
sie schon recht mit zwischen denen und
sicheres beim schwindegg wurde
und 32 habe schon gemerkt dass das eine
strecke ist für sie also sind wir der
vater verloren oder wird das sind halt
einen kontext kurz zuvor über wasser
gerettet oder was ich sie gefragt haben
und dann wesentlich größer und hoffe sie
geht jetzt nicht so eine erschöpfende
und tatsächlich als paar tage später
bekam ich das mal vor der steffen der
drehe ich wirklich zufällig sie sich
lieben wir dass sie nach und trafen
mehrere migräneattacken akademie ein
rückschlag ein monat nach häusern erster
treffer mache ich mich mit auf den weg
zu der rebecca ihre partnerin ist
unterdessen hat zurück wir haben schon
mal zum 3 1 ab gemacht aber der unia ist
so schlecht gegangen dass man hat diese
absage
[Gelächter]
der roma besser sie braucht aber nach
wie vor hilfe im haushalt und muss
lernen mit ihrer erschöpfung um 2 auf
dem sofa sitzt auch nicht daran dass ich
eben
das rätsel das nicht hacker union
ist mithin nicht allein und sobald ich
das opfer mit funktioniert ist das
management wirbt deshalb danke ich
brauche
jetzt aber jetzt wird die ovi
suite
sind
die kontakt und
medienmenschen wo
erschreckend dass ich so bin und wo
ich
bin und immer gut beraten und immer gut
gegangen
es zeigt
sich
dass nicht
die person
gut
aber ich glaube
nicht wirklich dass es
nicht so
schwierig
[Musik]
also
das ist
[Musik]
david
und ich
hallo
frau
tochter
und
das ist
ja
quasi
akzeptabler
familie zu bringen das ist
das schön zum schluss zeigt ich an david
und china nur die kritische kommentare
unter dem youtube
nicht viele zu sein sonst müsste danach
nicht gesucht werden ich bin in einer
facebook luca ronconi schweiz und des
ganzen hof aber noch viel viel viel
schlimmer dran sind als grafik und der
hand gar keine energie zum irgendwer
interview macher oder irgendwie bis der
rücken darf ich nicht mehr genäht einmal
zum werkschau die sind so
einfach wie
du denkst du wirst wenn du laut kobelt
patient die studios hergestellt dass ein
lügner du bist hergestellt dass er
schwächling als den feigling oder weiß
sie was ohne pauli tommy kennen wissen
dass sie weder noch vor dem bin
eigentlich auto vom weser herren vom
internat ja und dann lese ich der sache
[Musik]
für lehrer da es nur lässig gegen das
ganze macht monat lang
pascal of chronic öner 37
juli findet es cool oder wo das mache
jetzt mit messerscharfer sorry
ich weiß gar nicht was dann auch anne
hathaway
dankbar
auf der welt wo man
ist und dass ich so weit vorn und das
ist nicht ob die bestehende die in
dem film hat mir auf jeden fall zeigt
was für kraft muss wirklich gelang
comics labor betroffenen h und wird
physiotherapeuten von david gleitet es
geht ganz einfach krankheiten - cent und
betroffene die hand trotzdem s8 und
vorbehaltlich so und jetzt wird mich
wundern wie er findet dass wir als
gesellschaft seite mit zwiebel ankommt
und sie mit mir doch nicht kommen ich
freue mich auf den putz